Summer Sun and adventure for decades the
iconic VW campervan has been a symbol of
good times with family and friends
Volkswagen has manufactured 50,000 of
its t5 California model the fifth
generation van has been available for
the past ten years we're using the
occasion to take a closer look at this
popular ride
it helps me to my test driver sanik
Knapp has agreed to take the California
camper van for a spin and to explore
these hidden extras that have made the
model such a hit every good adventure
starts with a journey to exciting places
in true Volkswagen style the dashboard
is clearly laid out for ease of use the
seats are colorful which adds to the
spirit of fun the California
accommodates five people and it's not
only the back seat that is so generously
proportioned
when the Netaji tester sasha is chilling
out VW campervan style and tompa finds
ample sleeping place for two adults and
a child but there are also more beds
down below it's just a matter of setting
the thesis test he starts by folding the
back of the bench forwards then removes
the headrests and pulls the whole thing
forward then puts the back bench upright
again and folds it down into a bed
mattress is spread out on top you might
cut sauce by a couple more steps in the
trunk and the bed is ready with plenty
of space for luggage underneath
Offerman tax for those who like to sleep
in for a bit longer in the mornings
there's no need to worry about being
woken by the first light of dawn as our
tester discovers it is possible to zip
up the windows on the top deck while
down below there are blinds and curtains
for all windows and the really great
thing about them is that they are
magnetic which means they go in Edmonton
among neat and Fisker Mart so that's one
garnish long I ain't fair in most none
direct and what is they getting us for
[ __ ]
so within minutes the California beach
camper van is blacked out for a good
night's sleep
there are four diesel in to gasoline
models of the California beach available
you can also get them with
all-wheel-drive and dual clutch
transmission depending on the engine
prices in Germany start at thirty-eight
thousand six hundred euros for the
2-liter TDI with 62 kilowatts
their California sasha is impressed by
the amount of space in the California if
the bed up top isn't needed during the
day it can be pushed upwards to create
standing room said standing room is only
really necessary when getting in or out
of the Bands the tester is taken with
the little folding table tucked inside
the door designed to use both in and
outside the inside version he has to
unfold two legs and two little clips on
the other side then he attaches the
table to the left side of the van to
create the perfect place for breakfast
lunch and dinner
he says for playing cards and when the
playing or eating is done the table can
be pushed forward so there's no need to
climb over it to get out tester is
impressed with the W's attention to
detail and he cites that the table is
just one example when being used outside
there's no need to remove the back seats
to use it because the VW has gone the
extra distance and hidden two folding
chairs in a hatch dog in the first item
then I commit some item fall in or Sasha
collapses the California is a great van
for a short camping trip but in his view
attached too small for a longer
excursion and if it's just being used
for these shorter trips it works out to
be a pricey ride which is why he would
try to borrow one but those who do
decide to invest in the California often
stick with it because for comfort
seekers this model comes with many many
little built-in adventures